okay uh thanks for the introduction uh
so this is based on giant works with uh
Edo Bento talmoran and guys
so this Workshop is about secure
computation it's like the most General
problem in cryptography and uh on the
first day we saw that this is really
moving fast from Theory to practice the
major research effort in cryptography
right now and uh people are actually
looking at implementation and systems
issues in this uh in this area
so this talk is also going to be about
Bitcoin which is a decentralized digital
currency that provides some level of
anonymity it's one of the reasons why it
became very famous and it's also a
relatively widely adopted there's a lot
of recent research activity like this is
one of the few Bitcoin talks in this
Workshop uh Bitcoin is supposed to
securely Implement uh Implement a bank
and you can actually enable a wide
variety of transactions because of uh
because expressive power like it
supports uh Bitcoin scripts and time
logs which are a wide range of
applications uh some of these
applications are
Lottery gambling auction so these are
happening on the Bitcoin ecosystem
currently these are done using a trusted
party but these are already uh this is
stuff that's happening in Bitcoin
so this talk is about uh enhancing
secure computation so uh
second computation is great but what are
the issues with uh with traditional
secure computation
so here's like a partial list uh perhaps
the most the biggest problem is uh is
fairness in the presence of a dishonest
majority what we know is that it's uh
it's probably impossible uh in the
setting like even simple tasks like Fair
coin tossing is a is impossible so
people have started looking at like
several workarounds uh
Etc another issue is like resource
Finance so here
nobody gets the output of the
computation so it's kind of fair in the
traditional sense but still an honest
party waste resource is going to like
say until the end of the computation and
is expecting to get the output with the
other party has awarded let's say so it
has wasted computation and without
without even getting uh the final output
so this is uh this is some kind of
fairness that that we'll be interested
in another thing is the protocol
completion so this is something uh
secure competition in general cannot
guarantee especially in like multi-stage
reactive computation so even if you have
like ideal fire functionality you can
only do it for like one stage of the
competition you can get the outputs but
how do you enforce that parties Carry On
To The Next Stage so that is something
which is which is not clear
the obvious other issue with the
traditional NPC is that it does not
really handle cash the cash distribution
is uh uh it just involves like bit
strings and tuning machines so there's
no uh framework in place for this and
obviously this makes it like kind of
hard to uh
uh you know make it use NPC for like
real applications such as like auctions
Brokers stock markets like challenges
was talking about uh yesterday
and the next issue perhaps is uh
malicious compilers for MPC so here's um
there's been a lot of tremendous
progress in the last few years but still
the overhead is kind of Flushed and this
is also one of the issues which is uh
which we will try to you know enhance in
this in this talk
so um the way in which you're going to
enhance the secure computation is by
looking at some kind of a unified model
which calls the penalty model so in a
broad uh way like any deviating party
the adversary if edv is from the
protocol maybe it's fairness maybe it's
some protocol completion any type of
issue then we first said the adversary
is going to pay like uh like a monetary
penalty to the to the honest part so in
some sense both parties are starting
with some money and then if something
goes wrong then the honest part is
compensated with uh with mine so
obviously uh one main requirement is
that whenever an honest part is to lose
money
and uh the bad guys uh well they should
lose money if they debate and the money
that is lost should go to the honest
party right so uh in all the
enhancements that we are looking at like
fairness resource usage protocol
completion cash distribution NPC uh
malicious NPC so yeah we are going to
adopt this penalty model so the
adversary can deviate like for example
In fairness you can deviate you can
learn the output and a bot but then
we'll make sure that uh the honest part
is compensated according to this model
so uh so the type of applications that
we are that we will enable will be like
some Fair versions of lottery fairnesses
in this sense like in the penalty model
you can get the output and you can you
can avoid the computation but the honest
party will get compensated right so we
can enable like far versions of Lottery
Poker auctions markets and so many other
things
um so one way to look at our
applications is uh you know you can look
at them as like complex smart contracts
with uh with this like penalty thing in
in the contract
uh plus uh we will enable this to like
uh add its security and privacy
guarantees uh and what we will mainly
show in this talk is that how how to
build this like very complex contracts
from from very simple contracts so the
type of the several Notions of
Simplicity one might be interested in
and uh the notion that we will look at
is like some kind of stateless uh
contracts of these contracts don't the
simple contracts won't depend upon other
contracts and uh even in a multi-party
setting these contracts will only
involve like two parties but still they
will allow you to realize these complex
contracts uh in a multi-party setting so
this is the type of uh this is one way
to interpret our results
so this is the uh the simple
um the simple contract that we will be
using through this talk uh so this is
the claim or refund transaction
functionality so there are uh so this
involves only two parties and its
stateless in the following sense so
there is a sender and a designated
receiver the sender is going to deposit
some money to this functionality
and then it is going to specify some
some circuit free and a Time bound Tau
now uh the receiver has an option to
either claim it or or not claim it but
if it has to claim if it claims this
money then it has to do so within within
the specified time bound Tau and it has
to produce a witness tea that satisfies
fee so if it does it within the time
Montauk then it can then it can get the
money uh but if it does not do anything
then the money is just returned back to
the sender right but if it does claim
the witness then the witness is uh is
revealed to all parties so so I said it
involves only two parties but now I'm
saying the witness revealed to all
parties this is because uh the way this
uh this is just like an ideal
functionality version of this uh
uh of this uh contract in reality if
you've implemented over Bitcoin then uh
this whole contract is going to be there
in the public Ledger and everybody can
see if if something was cleaned the
transactions will be will be public to
all parties so this is okay
so uh so why this functionality is uh
very interesting to us is because uh
well this can be efficiently realized in
Bitcoin so Bitcoin provides the uh you
know it allows transaction to be
redeemed depending on like scripts and
also suppose like time logs which which
can capture this notion of time
and what is cool about this uh claim or
refund transaction function is that we
just abstract this particular thing
which is given by Bitcoin but now it can
be uh it allows for realization in and
across different models so you can you
can look at a different altcoin uh but
as long as it supports this Claymore
refund transaction functionality you can
still use our protocols you can also use
this uh if like PayPal for example
decides to decides to implement this
transaction functionality you can still
run our protocols as long as you trust
paper
so some of the efficiency metrics that
will yeah
a certain party or for
the pop is open to a designated receiver
so it's like for one receiver so this is
uh so everybody knows who the two
parties are
so the efficiency Matrix that we will be
interested in when realizing these
complex contracts from simple contracts
are the standard ones like you know so a
computation complexity communication
complexity or wrong complexity it
depends on on the specific application
that we are interested in
the other complexity measure which is
kind of new and unique to this uh to our
problem is the so-called validation
complexity
so this is the this actually tries to
capture the complexity of the scripts so
in the previous slide with the claim a
refund transaction so this is the
complexity of fee
so why is this complexity is important
is because uh for the transaction to be
validated in the Bitcoin Network kind of
every Miner has to accept this
transaction so they have to essentially
run fee and see whether the witness
actually corresponds to fee
so if you're done if your validation
complexity is low then obviously it's uh
you'll have faster validation you'll
also have a reduced load on on the
Bitcoin Network and in the future it's
possible that as your uh as your
complexity keeps growing you know at
some point miners might decide to Levy
some kind of a transaction fee on your
on your transactions so it's so so in
general like reducing this validation
complexity is an important uh is an
important thing
uh the other complexity method that we
might be interested in some of our
applications is this optimistic
complexity uh here you kind of typically
expect parties to behave honestly and
you optimize for this not necessarily
for worst case uh
so before you go into the construction
some practical issues uh about uh about
the about the protocols that we design
so clearly if you have an attack on
bitcoin and you break the claim a refund
transaction functionality our schemes
are broken
and in general we assume that who is
running our protocols they have a good
communication Network like there's no
denial of service or you have like some
workarounds around this because yes
first point is if we thought about doing
something
Bitcoin is broken then the fairness only
is broken but otherwise the protocol is
remains secure with the board for
example uh yeah it will be you'll see it
in the construction so it will be that
will be the case but we don't give like
the penalty guarantees anymore it'll
just be secured about it
uh right so we want uh we have some good
communication Network because in our
protocols will start penalizing
someone's supposed to supposed to do
something and he's not doing it so if
it's because uh this is some problem
with the network and it's not able to do
it then you will start losing money
and for some of the constructions we'll
also need the
slightly more complicated scripts than
the scripts that are currently supported
in Bitcoin there are many offers which
are blacklisted so our scripts do not
not all our protocols run directly on
bitcoin but uh there are some proposals
for all coins with uh during complete
scripts and uh if they if they happen
then then you can earn a product
consultant
or alternatively you can contact like
some specific mining pool and ask them
to mine your transactions uh and you pay
increased transaction fee so that is
also an option
uh constructions will use uh heavy
crypto in the sense that they'll use
gobble circuits snugs and musics and uh
but the efficiency of these Primitives
are expected to improve in the future so
so in the rest of the dog I will uh I
will talk about the enhancements to
secure computation I'll briefly describe
the problem uh and and the main results
for the first uh for fairness I will be
describing the result is slightly more
detailed for the rest will probably be
just a sliding object
so uh the first issue is fairness and
secure computation so um so fairness in
general is like exemplified by this uh
Fair exchange or contract signing
problem so where two parties want to
sign a contract but neither party wants
to go first because uh mentioned the
contract but the other party might just
take the contract and run away
uh so this problem and Fair coin tossing
and several like Fast secular
computation problems in general they are
probably impossible
and so we can uh so researchers have
looked at several workarounds so in this
particular line of work we'll be looking
at uh the workaround in the penalty
model so here we allow the adversary to
about after learning the output
but uh if it does so then it will pay
penalties to uh to all other parties
so I'm just going to summarize some of
the results that we know also giving
credit to to Prior work so uh it was a
protocol for two-party Lottery by back
in Bento and also a protocol by Stefan
zemboski's group at the University of
Warsaw uh for multi-party so these are
the first protocols uh at least to the
best of my knowledge which started using
a penalty model and tied it to bitcoin
uh following this there was a two-party
cycle computation product called by
Stefan's group and uh concurrently uh
there's a multi-party secure computation
protocol in the in this claimer refund
transaction hybrid model
and the validation complexity of this is
like independent of the of the function
that you're evaluating is just going to
be some hash verification depend on the
output length
so uh in subsequent works there have
been like efficiency improvements uh by
using slightly more complex contracts so
we are going to show a product called
using like simple contracts claim or
refund but you can use complex contracts
and uh and obtain some efficiency
improvements mainly in the wrong
complexity
so just to get a flavor of how we uh
model uh some of the complex contracts
so we model them just as like ideal
functionalities uh and but now they're
going to start dealing with money in
some sense right so so the way we
capture money is just like using some
very minimal model you just have coins
which don't um uh who these are
different from bit strings in the sense
that the coins change ownership when you
send from one party sends it to the
other party
so this is the type for like uh the
contract for secure computational
penalties if you ignore the stuff in
green you just get like standard secular
computation so everybody summons their
inputs and the functionality Returns the
output to the simulator and the
simulator has a chance whether to uh
whether to a board or to continue
uh when we for second computation
penalties now we ask everybody to
deposit some uh some coins so the coins
deposited by the honest parties are
going to be returned to them and the
simulator if we deposits like sufficient
number of coins namely H times Q where Q
is the penalty amount and next is the
number of honest parties that is like
sufficient to pay penalties just in case
the simulate robots right so uh so now
um if if it if it submit a sufficient
number of coins then it has a chance to
look at the output if it did not then uh
then the output is sent to All parties
uh it can look at the upper Underside
robot in which case uh the penalties are
distributed if it continues to I mean if
it decides to continue then it gets its
deposit back so this is the way this is
just the flavor of the ideal
functionality representation of our yeah
so it depends like uh it's a parameter
so you can write a theorem saying that D
should be so many so much times Q for
our protocols it will be something like
n times Q where n is the number of
parents but this is some parameter that
you can improve
defense for X multiple H times Q yeah so
I just mean like X less than HQ
yeah so I I mean in the actual protocol
and about will happen somewhere before
the the simulator extracts the coins so
this is just like a high level picture
so some details which are missing but
so functionality is it common for
functionality to use number of owners
parties inside I've never seen a
function is it even
yeah so you have the simulator and the
number of
it gets from the similar to all the
corrupt inputs and it has to get from
the other parties each other party
further
so uh so we are going to show how to
realize uh this uh Fair uh secure
computation from a simple contracts
right so first uh starting point is to
reduce the fast secure computation to
fire reconstruction so this is like a
general Paradigm which is used in
several previous books so in the first
step we are going to run like some
unfair secure computation which is going
to uh compute the output of f it is
going to additively secret share among n
parties then it's going to compute
commitments on each of these shares it's
going to make all the commitments public
with the ithd commitment is made public
only to the right party
so note that this is an unfair step and
is an unfair secret competition and the
adversary can abort during this step but
it will not learn any of the it will not
learn the outputs because at least one
of the shares is hidden uh because the
uh because there's at least one honest
party
so what we need to do is now a product
called for fire reconstruction everybody
reveals their shares and uh in a way
such that if an adversary does not
reveal the share then you have to
penalize penalizing
uh so we are going to use the following
notation to denote acclaimer refund
transactions the arrow notation from P1
P1 to P2 so it just means that P1 makes
a disclaimer refund deposit and P2 can
claim it uh within time Tau uh it can
claim the money if it reveals the
witness T within time Tau
it's our protocol is going to so after
this first step it's uh the protocol for
fat reconstruction apparent is just
going to be a sequence of
it's just going to be like a sequence of
these arrows the sequence of claim uh
claim and deposits so note that this uh
the fcr functionality itself does not
provide any kind of simultaneous
guarantee so someone can make a deposit
the other party can abort someone can
claim a deposit some subsequent party
can abort and you also have to deal with
malicious coalitions
so uh just going to go uh quickly over
uh our solution for this uh for this
problem so this we call as the ladder
protocol so there are two uh two phases
in this protocol the first is a roof is
where everybody makes a deposit to the
last party
and this can be claimed if if the last
party is going to produce all the all
the D commitments then you have like a
ladder step so these all the first first
deposits can be made simultaneously
it goes like one by one uh in like the
ice step party and minus let's just say
Pi is going to make a deposit to Pi
minus 1 saying that it can it can take
like something like I minus 1 times Q
coins if it produces the first I shares
so uh also the it can so so so one there
are two things to note first is that the
number of uh uh decomments that you need
to produce like it keeps increasing and
also the the penalty I mean the deposit
amount is also increasing like Q to q3q
although
so the reason we have uh we have this
like list of uh uh the D commitments
increasing is because uh this is just a
mechanism to provide to prevent uh
aborts in the deposit phase so you kind
of know that unless all the deposits are
made parties cannot start claiming from
the front and and avoid making other
deposits and the reason this uh this
amount goes from Q to Q so one is is to
prevent parties from aborting during the
claim so now if an honest party uh makes
a claim uh you can kind of observe that
uh it's already so so for example P2
will deposit q but then in the next step
it can it can get two times Q so it's
kind of already got the penalty amount
which it will lose if if PN is going to
take Cube Cube coins from so that is
like the the high level idea so um uh so
in some sense like at the at the end of
the in an honest execution so everybody
is able to claim so P1 makes produces T1
cleans the money now P2 knows T1 it
already knew T2 so it can claim uh uh P3
is deposit and and they keep going up So
eventually at the end when PN learns the
output when PN minus 1 reveals
everything else in some sense PN has uh
PN will actually pay n minus 1 times Q
coins to p n minus one but if you look
at it from a different angle it's as if
it has it has paid like few coins to
each of them because n minus 1 would
have paid like n minus two of those to p
n minus 2 and so on
so uh so this is our our protocol for uh
fire uh fire reconstruction penalties
from
from the simple uh from fcr
so next we go to like resource fairness
so here I'll just give like a couple of
examples about like the type of problems
that we uh that we have looked at so one
is the problem of verifiable computation
which um which I think you should have
heard in the in the first talk so here
we have like a computationally weak
client who's Outsourcing its competition
to a powerful server and uh so we want
the server to compute obviously there is
some incentive for the server and namely
it's uh is probably going to get some
money after it performs the competition
right so once we introduce mine you
already run into some kind of fairness
issues because you don't exactly know
when the client is go needs to pay the
server right so the client uh you know
if the client pays after he gets the
output if you schedule the money
transfer in that way then the server can
compute but the client never pays up so
the server is has wasted his resources
but has not gotten paid
if you make the client pay ahead of time
then the server just has no incentive to
to perform any computation because I
already got the money
right so uh so let me show and as one of
the results is like a fair scheme for
verifiable computation but where you
don't have this like fairness issues so
the high level idea is to run some kind
of a secure computation product called
to compile uh any verifiable computation
scheme into uh into a fair verifiable
computation scheme and here we again use
only only claimer refund transaction
functionalities
uh and the validation complexity of a
protocol is the is kind of proportional
to the client verification it's just
like a snack verification and it's not
uh it doesn't depend on on the on the
exact function that is being computed so
that is that is what is non-trivial
about this result
so uh next uh example for resource
fairness is uh is private simultaneous
messages so something you might have
heard in in Ivan's talk yesterday so
just going back to the model so
um so here we have like multiple clients
and one referee and the client share
some Randomness the clients are supposed
to send a single message which allows
the referee to learn uh learn the final
output of the function
so we can look at a variant of this
model where the referee is actually
paying for the output so it's willing to
pay for the output now uh the thing is
uh it has it will get the output only if
like both both the clients are sending
uh their messages and what happens is
that the honest client were obviously
compute but the design is client could
just deviate from the protocol it might
might not compute it might send like an
incorrect message so in this case the
referee is not going to get the output
so it doesn't make any sense for for him
to pay up so but the honest but the
honest client has kind of invested a lot
of computation so this this step could
for example be gobbling of a function
which might be might be a pretty
intensive task so it does it has
performed a lot of computations but all
this computation is going with because
uh the dishonest client hasn't done
anything right so it kind of in this
setting we would like to penalize the
dishonest client for not for not
participating in the protocol
so as one of the results in a
preliminary work we show a constant run
solution for this particular problem uh
in the climber refund transaction hybrid
model so it's no longer it's just a one
message protocol but we have like
constant rounds and the non-real part
about this construction is that the
validation complexity is independent of
of the actual garble circuits of the
actual function being computer is just
proportional to the to the input length
and the communication complexity will
still managed to keep it low it's four
times semi honest yeah so without this
uh resource fairness you you would get
like something like just one time semi
honest Yahoo but now it's a factor four
but you get this like resource file
notion
uh our next enhancements uh secure
protocol completion with penalties uh so
here we are going to consider like
reactive multi-stage computations and we
would like to penalize uh on our boards
like every honest party who's uh should
get compensated if an adversary just
supports in the middle so one thing that
I want to point out is that it does not
reduce to just the non-reactive guess
where you have a single shot computation
because uh fairness with Paradise just
works for a single stage it does not
guarantee that the next stage of
computational events start
so uh so we we have we are faced with
the challenge that aborts between stages
and during this stage also needs to be
penalized
and uh so this kind of a protocol
completion mechanism would would allow
us to realize uh cool applications like
multi-round adaptive fire exchange so
here you have parties having like a lot
of Commodities they are willing to
exchange like round by round and what
you need is like for the entire all the
rounds to be uh completed it's adaptive
in the sense that the parties can decide
which commodity to to exchange based on
the exchanges that happened in the
previous runs
uh you can also enable some applications
like mental poker where uh you know if
you're not able to capture all the
player strategies in a single shot
computation you can just look at it as a
reactive computation and and still Force
the the protocol to be completed
our functionality is already kind of
handling uh handling money in some sense
so it makes sense to look at a more
General notion of cash distribution
where uh where the functionality is
going to take both like uh you know
regular inputs as well as as well as
coins not just as a as a penalty deposit
but also as an input and then it can
compute the output of the function and
you know redistribute the coins that
were deposited depending on the output
of the function
so this is obviously uh uh ill I mean
ill solutions to several applications
like uh like Lottery you know auctions
the book stock markets markets in
general uh and this is the result uh
that we have about uh about this this
particular primitive so this is actually
introduced by you know work by Stefan at
all where they outlined uh uh that
something like this would be very cool
and uh and they scheduled a solution in
the two-party non-reactive problem uh in
a subsequent paper uh in a recent work
we uh we formalized and generalized this
primitive so what we can do now is we
can handle multi-party uh uh
computations and it can also be like
bounded reactors so it could be it could
happen in multiple stages and the whole
thing is that this is still secure I
mean secure cash distribution with
penalty so if someone robots in the
middle then they then they still pay up
to everybody so you can we can handle
bounded reactive and all of this is
still done using just the claimer refund
uh transaction uh the bad thing about
this protocol is that the validation
complexity is kind of not not very good
it's it's it's pretty high it's uh it's
it's proportional to the verification of
the underlying reactive MPC messages so
every NPC message will kind of need to
go through a claim or refund transaction
so this is very expensive
closed captioning not available
and uh the way so like with this and uh
with these enhancements in the penalty
model so we can kind of have like a more
realistic solution to some applications
which kind of really require families
like uh like a lot of gambling options
or markets so one way to review a result
is that we actually show realizations of
complex contracts uh with like increased
privacy and security but we actually uh
build this from like simple contracts
which have like very low validation
complexity they are stateless they don't
depend on other contracts and they they
involve only like two parties
so for future directions uh some of the
Notions like mainly like resource usage
for example uh we we don't have a very
good formalization and also uh
formalizations of Bitcoin itself is uh
is kind of open and you can also look at
like other ideal uh functionalities
transaction functionalities which can
heal the same type of applications
obviously are there like more
applications for which uh the claim or
refund transaction functional does not
really help so so those things are open
uh efficiency improvements is an obvious
open question some of our protocols for
example the fair uh the fairness with
penalties protocol takes like n rounds
and each round is like uh it's like 10
minutes if you put it on the Bitcoin
Network so it's obviously improving
their own complexity is uh circuit
interest
thank you thank you
though any questions
given that this is so General can they
actually build your own I don't know I
know variants of Bitcoin you know it's
kind of based on bitcoin and Transit so
so as long as you so you only need to uh
need a cryptocurrency which which
supports the claim or refund transaction
functional it could be any like Bitcoin
already suppose that with some like
limitations on the script size on on the
script complexity uh you could you could
build this on top of like any
cryptocurrency you can you can also
create your own currency which which is
tailored me to specific applications
like it can support so and so uh uh
scripts then it's then it's still fine
you can you can enable some applications
questions